[Music]
everybody is very jealous that I'm here
with you guys because everyone's so
excited to see this movie John Shu
called you guys and I quote The Avengers
of f'ing Asian movies do you feel like
superheroes of your culture right now I
think we're you know where the tip of
the iceberg when it comes to
representing what can be I mean this is
just one story of a multitude that she
should have been told many years ago so
for to be able to kind of break the ice
crack the door open I hope I hope that
people people enjoy the movie if
anything else I think so anxious another
reason because this movie means so much
to so many and I want people to enjoy it
and get out to the theater as a
superhero would be like they would know
I can't see and well the future is
bright because this movie gives you
everything it's like you guys i mean i
i'd i laughed i've shirtless scenes
everything is there I mean you know what
is it like to walk around with this guy
because he's good-looking he's British
or people stopping him in the streets
all the time I feel like a lots of it
yeah I have to fight them out know the
strange thing is like you know we've
we've filmed all these amazing movies
but the production process it's been a
year so it's this beautiful lull and
we've had like an amazing time to really
connect with everybody so I think it's
it's full steam ahead after this week
right but it is this is such a big
moment I mean and of course you've done
TV you guys have all done so much but
are you feeling like you're on the
precipice of okay this is about to be a
really huge thing for my career right
now
we either I guess no one really knows
exactly what's gonna happen we're
excited I mean for me I just hope it's
the beginning of something I
opens doors for other story to be told
like other original stories but just are
the diversity in you know in
storytelling like it could be you know
whatever whatever that you've never had
a chance to have your story tells people
I think Hollywood's finally waking up
realizing that people want to see you
want something fresh and new and
delightful
it's a universally scary thing to bring
somebody home to meet your family is it
even harder in Asian cultures than some
others what do you think I think it
depends on who you are you know there's
different severa teas of parents some
are more open than others have you guys
had intense experiences on your own
what's it like for you to bring somebody
home to your family I mean my parents
are pretty open and you know and so long
as the person with makes me happy that's
the most important things I think I'm
pretty lucky there to be honest yeah
aquafina said she just wants her parents
just want her to bring someone home
period
you have been having such an amazing
moment again like with everything that's
happening with the movie have loved all
these photo shoots you've Danny looks so
gorgeous how'd it feel for you to like
play blonde for a minute was that fun
I was I was blonde and I was pink it was
fun I had never done anything before and
I pretty much did it impulsively um yeah
it was fun and now I'm seeing myself
uncovers with that hair which is not
this did it feel a little bit like I
mean it's funny to see her her hair is
now so long with that wig nobody
recognized her without the wig on so she
come on sat without the wig on and the
crew be like oh do you do you need to
like be somewhere I don't know it's me I
Calvino like she was like incognito yeah
which is kind of amazing that she could
do that did you guys know about his past
as this host have you YouTube doll the
video see him because I'm from the UK
and so I'd seen you really you're BBC
yeah yeah that day you used to cut hair
yes yes
I tried to get him to cut my hair before
we this is the whole territory remember
that in the blonde and I thought
something was wrong I was like I'm just
gonna cut it myself
and then I did it you wouldn't do it
while I was on you I knew we'd get like
slaughtered by John yes you know that
I'm a compulsive to high pressure okay
so he saved you from yourself and once
in a while when he gets pushy Wow okay
so many past lives well we got a YouTube
travel video see if there's any of your
before and after and Constance how does
this feel for you to be again like I
mean you've done so much great work
before but now it's this big movie and
it's all happening how are you taking
this moment in I feel just so
tremendously lucky to have done my show
which was groundbreaking and historic
and to be going into it now and because
of that opportunity to meet all the
Asian American men and women who for
whom it's meant so much and to hear
their stories and to know that hopefully
we can be a part of a movement that
starts bringing their stories to life
because obviously our story doesn't
represent everybody hope it doesn't hope
they don't kind of like hair changes
that guy do well it's all in fun two
more quick questions um there are more
books of course what parts of the
sequels would you guys like to see
brought to the screen more of asteroids
when I read the book I was in or of that
character Jemma plays her impeccable eye
like in the third book they go into the
history so it's like when she was
younger and I think that's so
interesting and I like that part this so
there's a wealth of material yeah and
character is such a quiet power to her I
love that which she comes out in the end
[Music]
you